de ce musée du 21ème siècle alors
jacques violet françois granier l'on
avance visiter pour vous c'est une avant
première la science se reflétant dans le
futur la géode cette boule d'acier poli
de 36 mètres de diamètre qui abrite déjà
une salle de cinéma domine la cité des
sciences
un bâtiment gigantesque cent cinquante
mille mètres carrés de marbre gris de
poutrelles d'acier de façade de verre
270 mètres de long 110 de large et 42
aux deux fois et demie beaubourg
mais le jour de son inauguration le
temple des sciences est encore un
immense chantier impression de
gigantisme également à l'intérieur
dans le grand hall au centre du bâtiment
des escaliers roulants escale à 12
mètres de hauteur et permettent
d'accéder aux expositions permanentes
conçu pour tous les publics de 3 83 ans
on entre ici pour s'informer comprendre
manipuler participer au maximum
premier secteur le fond des mers et les
étoiles avec des maquettes grandeur
nature le sous marin français le nautile
et le troisième étage de la fusée ariane
des satellites des modules du
laboratoire spatial permettront de
prendre la vraie mesure des engins de
l'espace et comprendre la pesanteur sous
l'oeil d'un astronaute dans son fauteuil
volant dans la section mathématiques
l'audiovisuel associées à l'informatique
pour comprendre la force de coriolis le
théorème de pythagore où les lois de la
physique expliqué de façon attractive
dans le monde des sons un spectrographe
vous permettra de voir la trace de votre
voix sur un écran un couleurs
les enfants n'ont pas été oubliés pour
eux l'un vante orium où ils pourront
regarder vivre les fourmis sous la terre
et les poissons dans les aquariums
reste une question combien coûte cette
vulgarisation scientifique tous azimuts
réponse quatre milliards et demi pour la
construction du bâtiment 600 millions de
francs pour le fonctionnement en 86
certains parlent de gouffre financier la
ville est en a connu d'autres autant des
abattoirs un seul regret pour tous
aujourd'hui seulement un bon tiers des
activités sera ouvert au public le reste
comme le planétarium ouvrira dans le
courant de l'été